[Music]
in finally found news yeah finally
submitted by frankly chair Frankie J
what's the song that's real popular oh
that dude ready to go sugar sugar that's
right yes the other day yeah it is Thank
You Jade the other guy babyback babyback
we don't know [ __ ] yeah they were both
Mexican oh are you sure they're Mexican
a hundred anybody did that Spanish song
who are you talking about Frankie J oh
yeah that's one yeah
hella good no he's fire he's alright
everything a bottoms all right get the
[ __ ] out of here that's the nice thing
you too because it's really good it's
alright you should have one of the
sandwiches I'm basically an Italian mom
trapped in a Korean men's model my mom
single a woman found her brother's
murderer on Facebook 37 years after the
case went cold
Oh how did she do how god is somebody
kill my mom good I find that
[ __ ] took it I would help you
find your mother for some I'm not but
this is her brother
Oh brighter even if it's my brother even
if it's your brother and I knew you
loved it well finding this [ __ ]
he found that his brother who's the
murderer he found her brother's okay 37
years later how does she know that off
of like a federal quest picture that's
the boldest murderer move ever to kill
somebody's brother didn't get a friend
request
that would piss me off as the murderer
or as the the long receiving the request
the murderers probably pissed too it's
like [ __ ] can't have an account I
cancel my myspace is this [ __ ] alright
so in July 1978 the bodies of Chris and
his girlfriend Peeta were found floating
off the coast of Guatemala oh they were
childhood sweethearts
they loved adventuring through Central
America they would write home often they
would write letter
all the time so they would communicate
with their family and in one in the last
letter they said that they met this
American named Phyllis Boston and that
they were gonna that he was gonna give
them a ride to Honduras from Belize then
that's when their bodies were found
after their bodies were bound tortured
and weighed down by engine parts the
autopsy doctor said that the bodies were
monstrous damn oh my god what a
nightmare I would never trust American
overseas Eliza I know I just gotta
breeze past that one you guys understand
the logic we just don't understand Joe
yeah but and why yeah I love it why
Americans are so or so dangerous
yeah overseas well cause it's suspect
right it's like why would they be in
Central America and like when you go to
these different country you don't want
to be around Americans you're going
there to be with the locals right like
when I go to Japan I'm not trying to
hang out with other Americans they're
weird that's how you're gonna survive
you're smart but when you do meet them
you're not talking I know I'm [ __ ]
full of [ __ ] because every time I travel
all the English speakers kind of like
gravity gravitate toward each other and
we just kind of like make friends I just
gave you specially when you bend it for
a week a minute you hear English like an
80 even if it's UK English for Aussie
any type of English I just gave it to
you man then you didn't even like accept
it for like five seconds I know but I
don't lie that's why it's hard so I made
a statement and I [ __ ] said damn
that's not the truth though cuz I did
the opposite thing anyway this American
man had two young sons with him okay are
they saying that he's the one that was
involved in the torturing you know that
stuff might be family bonding and they
did it together
oh my god for some reason like all the
authorities involved here they kind of
let this dude kind of slip away because
they didn't have any hard evidence of
the crime but the son one of the sons
he's saying that he spent the last 30
years trying to convince authorities
that he and his brother saw these
murders have
oh wait they were trying to convince
someone that they saw it and you don't
want to believe that they say no I
wanted to believe them why I think
eyewitness testimony is not enough for
something they need others cuz maybe
maybe what it's like you're my dad and
then I [ __ ] hate you cuz you didn't
want to give me money and now i want to
pin this murder on you because i'm like
oh hey they're kind of all my dad's like
but if someone tries that hard 30 years
i mean that's a or maybe the guatemalan
police was like yeah right fool yeah
alright homes whatever fool you did see
nothing fool even the Harbormaster and
belief they confirmed that that couple
was with Silas when they left and then
once I was came back the couple wasn't
with them so it was just like dude
obviously this dude killed this couple
oh my god and he also had a history of
crime in his path did he lose his kids
probably damn that's so nuts man can you
imagine like your dad is a serial killer
and you watch him torture people and all
that [ __ ] and then like at the same time
though he's taking you on vacation no no
at the same time he was telling his kids
that he had killed 33 people and who
said if you ever tell anyone or you try
riding me I'm gonna kill you too while
he was killing while he was killing this
couple his dad was telling the boys if
you tell anyone that you saw this I'm
killing you too they were in the room
watching and hearing it was a book oh
how does that work with the law now
because technically they're a part of it
right but they're kids and then you said
they were trying to say something at 30
years yeah they were trying to convince
them they've been running from their dad
for like 30 years
well I don't know about running that's
probably damn good it's not on Facebook
yeah he ended up going to a nursery yeah
the whole point of the article bro
oh by the way I forgot to mention that
this fool Silas he was married seven
times and they all disappeared his third
wife disappeared oh she didn't disappear
they were they were Surrey investigating
whether or not he killed her to a so
popular people want to marry
hey obviously cuz he starting he's like
if you don't on the end your life that's
right and then almost like I want
divorce he goes okay like they were
taking a ride with him charming guy huh
they were abused by the fire by the way
I just read the confirmation and it's
two against one
but he's still overpowering ever trust a
stranger never trust a dad you could
trust him because he's got two kids I
don't give a [ __ ] if you got two keys
[ __ ] your two kids too I'm gonna [ __ ] I
don't trust nobody
well those kids nothing cuz they're good
kids ah I'm saying like in the situation
where I met a stranger right like just
because you have two kids doesn't mean I
trust you they could be like a part of
your whole little bandit group like they
just baked me in and [ __ ] [ __ ] your kids
too am I gonna be gone in like five
seconds bro no I'm a really skeptical
ass human being though especially out of
your own yes scenario right outside this
country on trust [ __ ] nobody dude it
could be a [ __ ] pastor with the cross
on his chest I'll snap that [ __ ] and put
in his eye [ __ ] what if it was like a
twin they got separated by birth and
he's like brother and you're like [ __ ]
you no you're not you're ugly [ __ ]
would you still do that
I still kill him so there's only one
yeah and then would you tell the
witnesses like I'll kill you if you say
anything why am i turning into a
murderer now you're trying it this guy
cuz you two are on Facebook and their
story is kinda similar or at least the
world you built yeah so penny is the
sister right so she so now fast forward
2015 she has been coping with her
brother's death over all this time her
own father died in 2013 so he never had
a chance to find out what really
happened to his son so then in 2015 in
October she typed in silence Boston into
Facebook and saw that a photo hmm he
even use his real name it wasn't him
that created this Facebook account he
went to a nursery home in the nurse or
the the nurse was trying to find him
friends cuz he was a lonely old man cuz
he's a killer or he told the nurse like
you better at all this who went through
all life killing all these people and
he's just a sweet little old man at a
nursery home and no one knows that's why
I always say it doesn't matter if
they're [ __ ] old you don't know what
the [ __ ] they were when they were
younger treat him like
right you treat them however they
[ __ ] treat you just because they're
all they don't get a pass he is the old
[ __ ] yeah just your age change you're
still a [ __ ] big [ __ ] laughs how to
go back like this pop into your brain
man old people yeah yeah man penny was
able to find those two sons she was able
to get written testimonies from the sons
detailing how Kris was still trying to
comfort PETA through everything telling
him like as they were being tortured as
she was probably being raped telling her
like everything will be okay and then
they were dumped overboard like the port
like the most horrible [ __ ] ever
finally in December 2016 December 2016
Silas was arrested and charged for those
murders by that time he's a drooling
potato what the [ __ ] but then this
[ __ ]
he was already bedridden due to illness
and age and he exercised his right to
withdraw medical services so he just
died on his own terms
he never liked the case never went to
trial because he died in April of 2017
that's wrong he should have been
tortured man yeah brought back from the
dead yeah Keith and Chris oh my god I
think she was a lawyer is that handsome
white man there were both professionals
professional travelers no I think you
were the doctors or not why does there
have to be some inner sadness in the
world people get away with crime like
that I don't get away yeah he was a
doctor and she was a lawyer that's a
power couple that's huge
dude he could have been saving people's
lives till this day there's a penny the
seat there that lost her bradder yeah
and then this is the photo of Silas and
there's two sons
look at that [ __ ] speedo man you know
that fool is dangerous yeah and then
this is penny with one of the sons that
told her everything
go business now or like right before
when she found him I bet you he still
would kill if he if he could yeah bro
he's still doing it being dead oh let me
get my hands on that [ __ ] piece of
[ __ ] let me get my hands on this feed oh
okay man I hate people like that they
get away I wish you know if there is a
god please do your duty and when people
get away in our world you [ __ ] his ass
up man that handsome guy was the
murderer no he was the victim the guy in
the speedo is the murderer
[ __ ] just has one red stripe or
different suspect as hell and in his his
son is all posing and [ __ ] with his hip
hop out like I mean these choices in
clothes just tells me what kind of an
individual here
[Laughter]
[Music]